dans la famille à l'idée il n'y a pas
que laeticia qui est amoureuse en ce
moment on le sait la femme de 44 ans vit
une romance avec l'homme d'affaires
français pascal bats lent mais l'une de
ses filles seraient elles aussi en
couple et c'est la plus jeune des deux
la petite joy 11 ans qui serait folle
amoureuse elle aussi bien que son compte
instagram soit privée la jeune fille a
tout de même laissé apparaître dans sa
bio qu'elle serait bien en couple grâce
à ce petit symbole qu'il a relié à un
certain jules que voici les deux
adolescents seraient ensemble depuis le
15 décembre dernier comme nous
l'indiquent le réseau social depuis joy
n'hésite pas à lâcher des petits coeurs
en dessous de toutes les photos de son
jules
bref c'est le grand amour alors à 11 ans
je yal'idée en couple choquer ou pas
choquer vous allez pas aller m'emmerder
la petite joy alors franchement je veux
bien aller allons-y je ne me reconnais
dans mon tartines sur laëtitia qui vous
voulez mais là franchement laissé la
pauvre qui a 11 ans n'avait pas envie de
tourner évidemment avait des mariannes à
tour c'est en milliards les petits
choqué oui je suis choquée qu'on le
montre à l'antenne d'un petit garçon n'a
rien demandé il se retrouve comme ça mis
en avant un peu partout sa vie mais
c'est sa vie privée donc aussi les
céliniens chercher parce que ma fille
qui a 12 ans ce week end a annoncé
qu'elle avait enchéri jeu suivant
toujours pas remis c'est normal bah non
c'est pas normal non
les gars parce qu'en tant aux parents
effectivement vous mettriez un frein des
changes public
on est en train oui on est en train un
grand train enfin 12 ans à 18 ans moi je
regarde à 18 avec mon fils c'est très
normal la petite fille c'est très mignon
ce qu'elle en fait le message
en plus de ben elle a révélé son nom
alors elle est un conte un stade qui est
bloquée privé en revanche sa soeur jade
qui est l'aîné de 15 ans elle elle
dévoile toutes les photos que c'était
elle se met beaucoup en scène comme
maman et j'adore ça comme elle aurait
cédé petite fille très petites filles
mais ça s'est très vite et on va mort
d'homme franchement allez allez allez